[Musique]
arrivant à la tête de notre famille
politique je me suis fixé un objectif
d'abord rassembler notre famille
politique et ensuite bâtir la france de
demain nous avons pour ça mis en place
une douzaine de forum qui rassemble à
chaque fois des élus nationaux des
députés des sénateurs mais aussi des
élus territoriaux des maires des
conseillers départementaux des
conseillers régionaux de nombreux
experts qui nous ont rejoints qui
viennent de l'administration mais aussi
des chefs d'entreprise des cadres
dirigeants des représentants du monde
consulaire et ensemble nous avons
préparé ce projet est avancé à travers
les 12 forum qui ont été mis en place et
qui nous permettent aujourd'hui sur
chacun des sujets de préoccupation des
français de poser un constat d'en tirer
une analyse et d'ouvrir des axes de
réflexion et c'est à cette période que
nous en sommes c'est à dire au moment où
le rapport d'étape est bouclé et il va
être diffusé très largement dans tous
les départements de france plus que
jamais nous avons besoin de vous nous
avons besoin que vous nous rejoignez
nous avons besoin de vous pour préparer
la france de demain ce projet alternatif
à l'actuelle équipe gouvernementale
et ça ça se fera dans un esprit de
rassemblement autour des républicains
venez avec nous pour bâtir ce beau
projet
[Musique]